Wow, can you believe the amount
of code we just waded through?
We first looked at templates
which are just strings.
They use delimiters to section off
where JavaScript data will appear.
Underscores template
function returns a function.
We then call this function with data.
Then we saw how backbone handles events.
It takes an event object and
stores an event and
callback function in
an _events property.
When the event is triggered on the
object, it runs the callback function.
And we just dug into how routing and
backbone.history work.
The app's router sets up the routes and
their callback function in
backbone.history.handlers.
Then backbone.history.start
watches the URL for changes.
If the URL matches a route,
then it runs the callback function.
These three abilities,
templates, events, and routing,
are key aspects of how frameworks make
developing complicated apps easier.
In the next lesson, we'll move from
looking at the inner workings of
Backbone to Angular,
a framework by Google.